speaking of losing faith in the system
the instrument daily wire the Southern
Poverty Law Center puts several parents
rights groups on its hate map alongside
the likes of the Ku Klux Klan we know
that the Southern Poverty Law Center you
know they are a far left far left
activist group about the far left as you
can possibly get which is saying
something and they have taken upon
themselves to be the the Arbiters of
what qualifies as hate what qualifies as
a hate group and so that even though it
looks like Tyler like we talked about
the uh the Human Rights Campaign
yesterday another far left group
declared a state of emergency and we
kind of laugh about that because they're
not a governmental entity so who cares
about them declaring a state of
emergency it seems a little bit like in
the office when Michael Scott walks out
of his office and shouts I declare
bankruptcy it's like it doesn't work
that way you can't just literally shout
it I declare
and you think it's the same thing the
Human Rights Campaign can't walk outside
of its offices and Shout state of
emergency and anything happens